[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 24 juin le 7-8 journal
pour faire le tour de l'actualité locale
d'un département des yvelines bienvenue
si vous nous rejoignez voici les titres
alors que la fin d'année scolaire
approche à grands pas que des examens se
déroulent en ce moment les élèves
d'elancourt eux ont fêté leur passage au
collège les jeunes ont été reçus à
l'occasion de six soirées à la salle du
prisme une cérémonie qui est une
tradition dans la ville dès que vit à
marseille à vélo en faveur du handicap
c'est le défi dans lequel s'est lancé
plusieurs personnes depuis le 18 juin
le but récolter des dons pour
l'association handi val de seine à un
jour de leur arrivée nous prendrons des
nouvelles du groupe medibelge modane à
l'origine du projet sera notre invité et
puis un spectacle participatif mêlant
des habitants des douze communes de
saint quentin en yvelines made in sky
est en préparation au théâtre national
et à la commanderie
une soirée de présentation a eu lieu
récemment pour trouver des participants
avant le début des répétitions
mais avant de développer ses titres les
électeurs de nouveau appelés aux urnes
ce dimanche le second tour des élections
régionales et départementales c'est le
27 juin une semaine après le premier
tour qui a été marqué par une forte
abstention en ile-de-france et dans les
yvelines 66% pour le scrutin
départemental quarante deux binômes sont
en lice prime pour le moment à la
majorité sortante de droite et du centre
en tête dans la quasi totalité des
cantons elle affrontera des candidats de
gauche dans 18 cantons
le rn à bonnières sur seine et à mantes
la jolie et la république en marche à
versailles 1
et du côté des régionales la présidente
sortante du conseil régional valérie
pécresse est en tête étaient en tête
c'est dimanche dernier elle fera face à
trois autres candidats jordan bardella
pour le rassemblement national laurent
saint martin pour lr em et julien bayou
d'europe écologie les verts troisième au
premier tour qui conduira la liste
d'union de la gauche derrière laquelle
s'est ralliée également le parti
socialiste et la france insoumise elle
lui est d'ailleurs l'ancien président
socialiste de la région ile-de-france
région qu'il a dirigée pendant dix sept
ans entre 1998 et 2000 15 c'est une
surprise jean paul huchon apporte son
soutien à valérie pécresse pour le
second tour l'ancien élu a indiqué qu'il
voterait pour celle qui lui a succédé
sans hésitation
la seule candidate à même d'assurer le
sérieux l'avenir l'espérance pour la
région selon ses propos rapportés dans
les colonnes du point
selon jean paul huchon l'alliance entre
europe ecologie les verts la france
insoumise et le parti socialiste et je
cite improvisé et désespéré un soutien
auquel s'est joint également l'ancien
premier ministre de françois hollande
manuel valls
[Musique]
c'est une tradition à elancourt les
élèves célèbrent leur passage au collège
avec une cérémonie organisée par la
municipalité est discours
applaudissements et remise de cadeaux
les jeunes ont été reçus durant cinq
soirées au prisme retour avec mélanie
poké pas de lancer de chapeau cette
année en raison du protocole sanitaire
après une édition 2010 est annulée en
raison de la crise la cérémonie 2021
s'est bien tenue et l'encours récompense
chaque année les futurs collégiens cet
été
en fait c'est quoi ce 6e et ont grandi
je vais rencontrer beaucoup de personnes
je vais apprendre beaucoup de l'img
beaucoup de matière ça sera un souvenir
et oui ce serait très important
j'étais un peu stressé au début mais
après il y avait mes copains donc quand
j'ai monté sur scène bernard rigoler
tout ça dans ta ils m'ont aidé près de
400 élèves de cm2 ont été reçus lors des
cinq soirées organisées au prisme du 14
au 22 juin ils se sont vus notamment
remettre un diplôme et une calculatrice
c'est important de donner des
renforcements positif aux enfants ils
ont besoin d'être aimés ils ont besoin
d'être reconnus et c'est comme ça que
quand ils se sentent reconnus ils
travaillent plus en plus d'efforts
donc c'est très important ils encourent
tous ces rites autour de l'engagement
scolaire de deux aussi de l'esprit
collectif de toutes les équipes sur les
profs les parents les enfants là et tout
le personnel qui les encadrent elle les
élans courtois seront en cm2 encore
quelques jours les vacances scolaires
d'été débute le 6 juillet prochain au
soir deux mois de repos avant d'entrer
dans le secondaire mais dans l'actualité
également déplacement ce jeudi soir de
gérald darmanin how i le ministre de
l'intérieur se rend dans la ville qui a
été fortement touchée par des
inondations cette semaine suite à de
violent épisode orageux il a échangé
avec les y vas y va échanger avec les
forces de l'ordre et les forces de
secours les habitants également sinistré
du quartier de tonkin nous reviendrons
sur cette visite dans une prochaine
édition
autre déplacement celui de la présidente
de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen s'est rendu à paris
hier mercredi puis seul sur le
territoire de paris saclay c'était dans
le cadre de l'approbation par les états
membres de l'ue eux du plan de relance
européen baptisé next generation elle a
notamment visité plusieurs
infrastructures technologiques situé
dans le cluster d'innovation aux côtés
du ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
et du secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes clément bonne
[Musique]
même si le soleil se fait plus discret
ces derniers jours l'été est bien là et
les risques qui sont liées aux 6es la
ligue contre le cancer organise jusqu'au
27 juin une campagne de sensibilisation
sur les effets du soleil sur la peau
astrid bergère a interrogé le président
de l'antenne y vino ans de l'association
et nous donne des précisions et des
conseils regarder il y à tous les ans 80
mille cas de cancers de la peau dont 10
15 % sont des mélanomes donc vraiment
grave et c'est un cancer qui tend nette
progression année après année du fait
des expositions au soleil
[Musique]
chaque année avec un capital plus ou
moins importants fonction de sa peau
mais si vous voulez quand on voit par
exemple des jeunes enfants de moins de
10 ans ou de moins nous de moins de 10
ans par exemple qui effectivement sont
exposés au soleil on considère six ans
la peau claire qui sont en train de
gaspiller leur potentiel de résistance
aux au mélanome au carcinome et donc si
vous voulez il ya un gaspillage de ce
capital qui est dramatique ne pas
s'exposer systématiquement entre 12h et
16h face elle serait la règle absolue
mais surtout surtout alors prenez vos
responsabilités mais surtout pour les
enfants surtout pour les enfants les
jeunes enfants véritablement la crème
solaire
le chapeau le tee shirt etc il faut
penser à se protéger sur protéger et
réitéré sa protection régulièrement ne
pas tenir compte du fait que robert
maintenant il ya moins de soleil ou où
le ciel est voilé
c'est pareil maintenant qu'il faut
véritablement le pôle fin une fois une
fois dans la journée simplement nello
répété répété l'opération plusieurs fois
par jour une initiative solidaire à
présent qui a été lancé la semaine
dernière et qui devrait normalement se
clôturer demain un périple dès que vie
à marseille avait été 900 km en faveur
du handicap et des filles dans lequel
s'est lancé une quarantaine de personnes
le 18 juin dernier le but récolter des
dons pour l'association handi val de
seine
alors pour en parler il ya toute
l'équipe et il ya notamment mehdi ben
modane bonsoir elle vous est à
l'initiative du projet de l'association
balrog timmins qui est donc derrière
derrière ce projet je vous laisse faire
rapidement les présentations iliaque et
avec vous c'est ça du coup je suis
entouré d'un groupe de 12 personnes vous
n'avez jamais lé omar tall est jeremy
hellickson amadou appartient jeunes qui
fait partie de l'institut national des
jeunes aveugles qui nous suit avec son
ton proche avec un tandem avec le plus
soin bonsoir à vous tous du coup alors
je le disais vous êtes lancer dans ce
défi depuis le 10 juin 18 juin la
première question est ce que l'objectif
va être rempli ce que vous allez réussir
à rejoindre la ville de marseille dès
demain franchement ça n'a pas été facile
mais on va tout faire pour
c'est quoi qu'il arrive on va y arriver
vous êtes tellement là on s'est arrêté
dans un village quelques kilomètres
avant donc ça veut dire il avoue rester
à peu près combien de kilomètres à
parcourir
il nous reste 150
alors vous étiez me semble 18 juin une
quarantaine à prendre le départ
aujourd'hui vous le dites vous êtes 12
ans et ça encore à faire ce périple
jusqu'à marseille c'est ça et ça et donc
du coup ce qui est intéressant c'est
aussi une diversité dans les
participants c'est ce que j'ai pu lire
dans des articles de présentation vous
le disiez il ya des personnes qui vous
accompagnent notamment une personne en
situation de handicap par rapport à la
première journée on va commencer avec le
plus jeune qui avait 9 ans et le plus
ancien de va avoir 65 ans là dans les
très bons et très exactement les
transmissions qui reste ça va de 16 27
ans j'avais attaqué en situation
d'handicap si les non voyants
il avait par exemple cette année
l'appétissant eu un accident très
rapidement j'ai un petit morceau de
jambe en moins mais tout va bien
après on a des pompiers les militaires
des étudiants des éducateurs vitaly ça
mais on est tous réunis
rappelons le ce périple c'est en faveur
du handicap alors plus précisément en
faveur d'une association qui s'appelle
andy val de seine
il ya des dons 1 c'est ça qui sont
collectés comment sont-ils collecter
vous avez lancé une collecte une une
campagne de financement sur internet
c'est sa jolie et après aussi on a
réussi à avoir des sponsors notamment
pour le crédit agricole
le siège la nacelle pardo le magasin
easynet store et puis après on a pas mal
de pas mal de dos on a eu la part de
tous les gens qui ont pu être grande de
notre projet des gens qu'on a rencontrés
sur le trajet oui et par ailleurs on a
pu bon voilà aussi une grosse tombe
alors qu'il y avait 80 le va gagner et
les gens étaient présents et ont acheté
des tickets tout ça sans fin avec un
tirage de la tombola il me semble à peu
près tous les jours c'est ça vous vous
relisez des vidéos sur votre page
facebook
quand on n'a pas trop de mésaventure on
essaie de faire ça tous les soirs il ya
donc comme il ya plus de quatre mois par
l'oph une dizaine de lots par jour on va
y revenir sur ce périple
concrètement ça va servir à financer est
ce qu'il ya des projets spécifiques que
vous souhaiter financer
au travers de cette association handi
val de seine ouais tout à fait vraiment
un projet de voyage vaut vraiment leur
offrir la possibilité de s'évader de
voir autre chose
ils ont passé une année assez difficile
on aura tous véhicules confinement mais
l'étude d'une manière un peu plus
strictes donc je pense que ça va être
l'occasion de de souffler un peu et de
leur donner un peu de bonheur
en alliant nous le côté sportif et le
côté solidaire racontez nous un peu
votre semaine on imagine que ça a été
difficile il ya de violents épisodes
orageux qui ont touché la france
j'imagine que ça a été difficile de
continuer on va dire dans de bonnes
conditions avec cette pluie qui a été
présente
on l'a vu à nombreux à nombreuses
reprises sur ce voyage je pense qu'on a
choisi mauvaise semaine on a eu un seul
jour de beau temps c'est aujourd'hui
départ et puis après c'était aux arènes
en les pires conditions pour pour des
campeurs quoi quel est le moral
aujourd'hui l'état du moral des troupes
est ce que il est encore bon terminé
vous êtes là qu'est ce qui vous a
justement permis de ne pas lâcher parce
qu'on a compris des conditions
difficiles s'est il ya un projet on l'a
compris derrière un grand projet
solidaire qui vous tient à coeur c'est
ça c'est l'esprit groulx et puis à
chaque fois qu'on va aller d'une étape
en fait on a un peu repousser nos
limites c'est encourageant pour le
lendemain et s'apprécient
on est ensemble quoi qu'il arrive qu'il
y en a qui faiblissent j'en ai pris un
petit coup de mou on sera toujours là
pour se pousser et à avancer et la cause
c'est le handicap derrière oui derrière
il ya des gens qui comptent sur nous une
belle action à tenir et à mener jusqu'au
bout et on a tellement fait comme et
c'est qu'on est obligé d'aller au et
vous le faites ce périple on le rappelle
avait été des vtt en plus qui sont assez
lourds qui sont équipées de portes
bagages je crois que c'est une quinzaine
de kilos par vtt c'est ça ouais une
quinzaine de kilos il ya eu beaucoup de
crevaison je crois qu'il ya un champion
vient champions derrière si j'ai bien
suivi les vidéos des crevaisons
au début on a accroché les chambres là
sur le coup et une dernière question est
ce que vous avez pu faire des rencontres
qui vous ont marqués peut-être est-ce
que vous allez en garde un grand
souvenir parce que il me semble aussi
que l'objectif c'était de rencontrer des
associations
ouais association d'apple pendant faire
beaucoup beaucoup de rencontres là des
cycles est à des six qui a stagné fait
que sa place et bastia qui luttent pour
la mobilité à vélo qui a décidé d'en
fait de finir le parcours avec nous et
c'était super sympa d'échangés parce que
du coup ça nous permet de nous connaître
l'endroit où on est et après c'est aussi
surtout sur la générosité des gens qu'on
a pu croiser quand on avait des
difficultés
en tout cas on peut retrouver vos
aventures sur la page facebook
le lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
d'ailleurs je précise ce que vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure qu'il est une
cagnotte en ligne qui est toujours
active et on peut bien sûr vous venir en
aide et et apporté son soutien à cette
initiative d'ailleurs merci et bravo
mais dit mme bravo à tous pour pour
cette initiative et on vous souhaite bon
courage pour la concept parcours merci
d'avoir été avec nous on voit une séance
de dédicaces à présent au profit des
enfants hospitalisés elle était
organisée par le collectif mon cartable
connectés récemment à versailles abdel
aïssou coauteur du livre étaient
présents pour sensibiliser présenter cet
ouvrage qui permet aux enfants malades
de garder le lien avec l'école
le prix jean et nicolas d'andré mon
cartable quelle histoire c'est le nom du
livre dédicacé par abdel aïssou à
versailles le 19 juin dernier 26
personnalités ont participé à cet
ouvrage
amel bent raymond domenech dominique de
villepin ou encore grand corps malade
ces personnalités on raconte un souvenir
d'enfance de leurs cartables et ce livre
est vendu au profit de l'association
le collectif mon cartable connectés qui
permet aux enfants gravement malades
hospitalisés de garder le lien avec leur
classe
le livre est vendu 8 euros dont 7 iront
directement aux enfants hospitalisés le
collectif et soutenu par l'association
de ladies circle qui aident à
sensibiliser les passants c'est vrai que
l'exclusion que provoque
l'hospitalisation des enfants et quand
extrêmement importante
donc on voit là on leur explique c'est
un sourire sur le visage d'un enfant que
d'acheter ce livre est de permettre aux
cartables connectés de garder contact
avec ses camarades touchés par cette
action de nombreuses personnes se sont
déplacées à la librairie du livre bleu
pour l'occasion
je trouve que c'est une très très bonne
initiative ça permet effectivement de
maintenir le lien avec l'élève c'est
très compliqué pour des élèves qui
s'efforcent on en a en ce moment
actuellement dans notre collège jeunes
qui suit un traitement très lourd et
malgré tout l'école c'est la vie normale
pour ses élèves
grâce à ces actions d'ampleur nationale
le collectif mon cartable connectés
espère pouvoir aider à l'inclusion de
près de deux millions d'enfants
hospitalisés chaque année la direction
villepreux à présent ou un ciné débat
était organisé dernièrement au théâtre
de la ville le film présenté au nom de
la terre témoignent des difficultés et
parfois même de la détresse vécue par
les agriculteurs d'un des acteurs du
film était même sur place pour en parler
est le reportage de nicolas landry et
d'eléonore sinoquet qui de mieux qu'un
acteur du casting d'un film pour le
présenter
c'était le rôle de jacques mars idir
fussent lors du ciné débat autour du
film au nom de la terre à vivre samedi
19 juin dernier et sa part sur eux
faire un constat bizarre c'est que deux
agriculteurs presque par jour se suicide
en france donc c'est l'histoire d'un
petit gars qui regarde son père et son
grand-père évoluer dans les soucis de
l'agriculture et qui essaie de se faire
une opinion pour savoir si lui il va
devenir agriculteur ou pas ce qui est la
grande question qu'est ce qui ferait de
nous un agriculteur aujourd'hui en
france ou bien est-ce que c'est un
métier trop dangereux après la diffusion
du film en début de soirée un débat a eu
lieu autour des problématiques de
l'agriculture
c'est un film pour moi qui ai juste
intéressant dans le sens où rim entre
une réalité de l'agriculture qu'on voit
pas souvent qui est souvent tabou parce
que ce sont des métiers où il ya
beaucoup de fierté de pudeur et il a au
moins cet vraiment se mérite d'oser
mettre des mots ou des fois des non-dits
mais qui en disent beaucoup sur
certaines particularités de
l'agriculture et pas forcément qu'on
aime voir où le meilleur aspect mais qui
est une réalité quotidienne pour
certains ce moment des changes a été
organisé par la première adjointe de la
ville
avec aussi un objectif d'ouvrir le débat
sur les enjeux de l'agriculture de
demain se fournir à proximité chez des
producteurs
de la région manger des produits de
saison évitez aussi les intermédiaires
les intermédiaires qui prennent à chaque
fois des marges
du coup c'est un moyen de permettre aux
agriculteurs de produire bien d'être
fiers de leur production et c'est aussi
une solution gagnant gagnant puisque les
consommateurs eux parviennent à donner
du sens à leur consommation peut être
une partie de la solution pour que les
agriculteurs ne soit pas demain comme
dans le film au nom de la terre au pied
du mur avant de refermer ce journal le
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
la commanderie prépare un nouveau
spectacle à la rentrée particularité
tous les habitants de l'agglomération
peuvent-ils prendre part pour présenter
le projet une réunion a eu lieu au
théâtre le but de trouver des
participants avant les répétitions
célia tsongo made in sky c'est le nom de
la création chorégraphique y aura lieu
le 19 septembre à la commanderie à
elancourt tout saint quentinois peut y
participer
une soirée de présentation avait lieu au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
partenaires du projet faire en sorte que
le public puisse participer à des
projets comme ça des projets collectifs
c'est toujours d aventure humaine
incroyable c'est vraiment du partage de
la rencontre c'est rentrer dans
l'univers d'un artiste d'un chorégraphe
et la chorégraphe du projet s'appelle
joanne leighton
c'est elle qui a proposé le made in afin
quentin en yvelines
c'est un gros travail collective ou en
participer individuellement pour former
cette pièce collective
on utilise les images
deux cascades de franche et de rivières
de glace et on s'inspire de ces images
pour en fait men et les mouvements de
danse sur scène il y aura cinq danseurs
professionnels accompagnés d'une
centaine d'amateurs du territoire la
pièce durera en tout 40 minutes on aura
les musiques qui sont lancés en live en
direct qui sont mixés en direct avec le
spectacle il y aussi noble fille avec
deux grandes sphères à genté qui sont
dans l'espace avec nous l'idée de ces
projets participatifs
aucun niveau technique n'est requis à la
commanderie la mission danse propose de
nombreux projets du même genre on a tout
un groupe assez important de gens qui
sont friands de projets participatifs et
avec cette année qu'on vient de vivre il
était un peu en manque donc commencer la
nouvelle saison avec un projet
participatif la scène nous réjouit et sa
région à la fois aussi les habitants les
premiers ateliers débuteront samedi 11
et dimanche 12 septembre au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous pouvez encore vous inscrire d'ici
là il reste des places
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]